So you want to be a solutions architect
working at AWS. AWS solutions architect
interviews have been changed
significantly in recent times. So if you
are someone who want to become a SA in
2026, I'm going to go over the updated
interview process. How does it change
based on different solutions architect
roles? Also, I'm going to answer one
popular question I get is is it easier
to get into AWS as a non-solutions
architect role and then switch
internally to SA afterwards. So keep
watching. I'm going to cover all of this
and more. For those of you who are new
to the channel, my name is Raj.
Currently, I'm a founder of a stealth ed
tech startup. Previously, I was a
principal solutions architect at AWS
where I implemented multiple world scale
projects which went on to become
official AWS references. And I have
mentored many students who got into AWS
as well as other top companies
Microsoft, Google, Reddit, JP Morgan,
Scoreweave, etc. On that note, if you
want to take this one level deeper and
want to get trained personally by me,
check out www.sabootcamp.com.
All right, now let's get started. There
are different solutions architect roles
at AWS. The most common ones are general
solutions architect also known as
enterprise architect or account SA. Then
we have partner solutions architect.
Then we have specialist solutions
architect and now AWS also hire
solutions architect in professional
services. They are known as delivery
consultant or infrastructure architect.
For all these essay roles first of
course recruiter is going to talk to you
and then there can be an optional online
assessment round. This is based on
hiring manager like if hiring manager
thinks you have plenty of experience and
you can go to the actual interview round
directly then you don't have to give
this online assessment. However, based
on the feedback from my students most of
the candidates go through this online
assessment. This online assessment is
like the name says online nonproctored
and you can uh save your progress take a
break and come back. However, if you sit
down and do it in one go, you have
around 1 hour to complete this. There is
both technical and behavioral section
for this online assessment. And these
are all simulated scenario-based
questions. So, you may be asked, hey, I
have this application and it's
struggling to keep up with high traffic.
What will you do to make it scalable?
Right? So, then there will be multiple
choices. So, you're going to select the
appropriate uh choices. Same thing for
behavioral. They will say your customer
is asking you to do this. How will you
go about it? You pick from the options.
Now, one thing people mess up is they
don't prioritize the behavioral uh part.
However, Amazon leadership principles
are given a lot of importance inside
Amazon. Like when I was working there,
we were using it all the time and we
refer it, right? Based on bias for
action, let's do this. Uh based on a
customer obsession, we should do this,
right? So make sure you study those uh
so that you can answer those simulated
behavioral leadership questions. Now the
level for the technical questions are
between solutions architect associate
and solutions architect professional
exam. So you don't need to like know
super deep but as long as you have good
understanding of services in compute
network storage security you should be
fine. After you pass this online
assessment, then the actual interviews
with human start. The first round is
telephonic round. Now for all interview
rounds, telephonic and afterwards with
actual people, there will be only one
interviewer for all AWS rounds.
Sometimes there could be another person
who will mostly be shadowing or reverse
shadowing. So unlike some other
companies, you don't have to worry about
multiple interviewers. They are all
asking you questions and basically you
have to prioritize some questions,
navigate that none of that stuff for
AWS. Now this telephonic round is mostly
technical question answer. Uh questions
will change based on your role. So let's
say if you are going for a specialist
role let's say containers, you will get
a little bit more questions on
containers, right? If you're going for
genai specialist SA role, you will get
more questions on genai. However,
irrespective of the role, you have to
have a good breath of knowledge. So
let's say you are going for genera role,
you still need to know about
microservices, devops, what is container
and that kind of stuff. Why? Because
when I says go talk to customers,
sometimes customer ask questions that's
on their mind, right? Like when you are
going to customers talking about
containers, they might ask me like Raj,
I saw this new geni announcement. Can
you tell me a little bit more? So you're
not expected to go super deep on those.
However, you need to have breadth of
knowledge. Another thing is the
questions will not be based entirely on
your resume. Okay? Because depending on
the role, hiring manager want the
interviewer to evaluate you on certain
areas. If that area is not in your
resume, it's not like they are not going
to ask you that question. So at AWS, the
job of your resume is to get you into
the interview. And in the interview, we
are going to test you based on how much
you know. There may be few questions if
the areas I'm trying to evaluate
overlaps with the work you have done,
but it's not like we are only going to
ask you questions from the resume. Most
of the telephonic interview questions
will be technical. However, expect one
or two behavioral questions towards the
end. But more importance is on the
technical part. So if you do a good job
at the technical part, if you do not do
terribly, you will be passed to the next
round which is loop. The infamous loop
generally has five rounds. Out of those
five rounds, three rounds are
behavioral. So make sure to study the
Amazon leadership principle questions. I
have a sample question answer with bad
answer, good answer. So check that video
out that might be helpful. Now compared
to the online assessment behavioral this
is all based on your actual experience.
What do I mean in online assessment AWS
gave you some simulated scenario. Here
interviewers will ask you tell me a time
you have done this. Tell me a time you
have gone above and beyond. Tell me a
time where you had to solve a complex
problem. This is how we evaluate your
work experience. Not just looking at the
resumeumé but you have to give example
of your actual projects that aligns with
the Amazon leadership principles. Now
sometimes you may get a little lucky.
Some recruiters tell the candidates what
leadership principles will be asked at
what round. Sometimes they even tell you
who is the bar raiser. But expect no
additional information. These are nice
to have. When I gave interview at AWS, I
didn't even know who is the bar raiser,
what kind of leadership principle they
will ask me. So I prepared for
everything and that's how you should do
it. On the note of bar raiser, quite
easy to figure out who the bar raiser
is. Like once you get the name of the
interviewers, you can go to the LinkedIn
and then if you see one person who is
not in that group that is interviewing
you, then you know he or she is a bar
raiser. The way I teach my student is
you should approach every round as the
bar riser round. So you should be aiming
to give your best answers at every
round. Also, it is not true anymore that
bar riser has the complete veto power.
If the hiring manager really likes you
and you did really well in the system
design round, which I'm going to come
next and so even if bar riser did not
like you that much, there is a high
chance you will get in. Right? So it's
not true anymore that bar riser can veto
you completely even if four other
interviewer said yes to you. So here the
behavioral rounds remain similar across
all SA roles but the other two rounds
will change based on your role. So for
almost all SA roles you will have a
system design round where the
interviewer will give you system to
design and then you have to design based
on that. here based on your role
interviewer will go a little bit deeper
in the same system design round they
will evaluate your tech depth as well.
So let's say you are going for general
essay then they will ask you deeper
questions on let's say security
scalability performance optimization
cost etc. But let's say you are going
for a container specialist role. So
expect deeper questions on that. Right?
If you're going for geni specialist SO
expect deeper questions on that. Now
another important thing is for nonp
profofessional services roles you will
not have a coding round. But if you are
going interview for professional
services role so like delivery
consultant or infrastructure solutions
architect you will have a coding round
but not traditional programming
language. It changes team to team. They
will test you on your infrastructure as
code like cloud form, terraform or
devops. Right? Some team may test you on
your scripting skill. But I have not
heard that infrastructure solutions
architect put through lit code. So you
don't have to worry about lit code data
structure algorithm. But you will have
hands-on infrastructure as code round or
genkins file round based on what kind of
implementation the professional services
team is doing. And they might have a
dedicated tech depth round with one
leadership principle. So basically three
dedicated behavioral round and then one
system design round another round with a
mix of deeper technical questions and
leadership principle. And I think you
guessed it like the technical questions
at this stage will change based on the
role you are going for. Like if you're
going for infrastructure solutions
architect, they might ask you deeper on
troubleshooting some stuff that you
might face when you are actually
implementing the solution. Whereas for
general SA they might ask you deeper
questions on how to navigate certain
design challenges. Now there is another
optional part in this uh loop. Sometimes
there is a presentation round.
Previously when I gave interview and
even few years back this presentation
round all the interviewers would be
present. That's not the case anymore.
Now the presentation round is taken by
the hiring manager. So hiring manager
will have one or two LP questions and
then the presentation part will take 25
30 minutes. You will present for 20
minutes and then question answer 10
minutes. Because this round is taken by
hiring manager, you are not expected to
go super deep on the technical part.
Hiring manager is evaluating you on your
communication skill, executive and
strategic presentation as well as some
technical. Don't make the presentation
all about technical. Think about the
business aspect and the executive aspect
as well. All right. So now you
understand all the rounds for solutions
architects. So is it easier to get into
Amazon as a nonSA and then it's easier
to switch? Not necessarily because this
behavioral rounds will be present for
all AWS positions, right? So if you're
going for TAM, if you're going for CSMS,
account manager, there will be these
behavioral rounds and they will see your
leadership principle capability and then
there will be separate rounds based on
the role. For example, if you are going
for account manager role or customer
success manager role, they will ask you
to write something and then they will
evaluate your writing, right? So, it's
not like other roles are easier. They're
just different and you should always go
for the roles that you think you have
the best shot at. So, if you are someone
who has been an architect or know lot of
technical stuff then TAM or solutions
architect is your best best bet. If you
are someone who deals with strategy and
growing some particular product then
being an account manager is better for
you. Once you get in there is no point
of you changing as well. However, there
is a switch that happens a lot more than
others which is TAM to SA uh because
there are a lot of overlaps on the
technical part. When it comes to
switching some teams now AWS is doing
this that you have to be in the role for
at least one year. So you get in you
have to be in that role for one year
then you can switch. Another thing is
the lower your level it's easier to
switch. So if you are L4 at that level
it's a little bit easier to switch
teams. L5 little bit harder but not too
bad. L6 which is senior essay becomes
harder than L7 principal essay is rare
because when you are trying to switch
from let's say L7 account manager to L7
SA principal essays come with lot of
additional uh responsibilities and they
want to see that you have a track record
because L7 SS are get paid highly. So
have students who have successfully
switched L5 L6 TAM to L5 L6 support TAM
to L5 L6 SS. So, it's doable, but again,
don't think the interviews will be
easier if you're going for TAM. It's
just different. All right, folks.
Hopefully, that clarifies some of the
doubt in your mind. Best of luck in
2026. Hopefully, you get into AWS as a
solutions architect. That's it for this
one. I'll see you guys and girls in the
next one. Bye.